in the midst of this massive economic
boom under President Trump it is
stunning how Democrats simply refuse to
learn if Trump's for it they're against
it even on issues they used to be for
like look at how they've refused for
instance to work with Trump on
legalizing the dreamers or even maybe on
prison reform they won't work with them
well we now see that anti Trump delirium
is pushing Democrats further out of the
American mainstream right to socialism a
new Gallup poll confirms that more
Democrats prefer socialism to capitalism
57% view socialism favorably while just
47% have a favorable view of capitalism
just two years ago those numbers were
flipped 56% then favored capitalism of
course it could be that socialism's
attractive new poster girl is changing
minds do you think that the future of
the Democratic Party is socialism well
first of all there's a huge difference
between socialism and democratic
socialism democratic socialism and
really what what that boils down to me
is the basic belief that I believe that
in a moral and and wealthy America in a
moral and modern America no person
should be too poor to live in this case
Trump believes that - that's why he's
growing the economy so fast well or
maybe it's the adopter nation against
capitalism on college campuses for
instance at Middlebury College juniors
can take a class called beyond
intersectionality developing anti-racist
and anti-capitalist feminism's a
University of Michigan textbook used for
activism class teaches that capitalism
should be overthrown and according to
data from open syllabus project Karl
Marx is the most assigned economist in
u.s. college classes today
great what college students this would
benefit from is a little less rage and a
little more reality like this
devastating exchange now this goes back
to the 70s one of my favorites between
Nobel Prize
winning economist Milton Friedman and
old lefty Phil Donahue it should be
required viewing when you when you see
the greed and the concentration of power
with it daren't you ever did you ever
have a moment of doubt about capitalism
and whether Greed's a good idea to run
on well first of all tell me is there
some society you know that doesn't run
on greed you think Russia doesn't run on
greed you think China doesn't run on
greed
what is greed of course none of us are
greedy it's only the other fellow who's
crazy this the world runs on individuals
pursuing their separate enters the great
achievements of civilization have not
come from government bureaus Einstein
didn't construct his theory under order
from a from a bureaucrat Henry Ford
didn't revolutionize the automobile
industry that way in the only cases in
which the masses have escaped from the
kind of grinding poverty you're talking
about the only cases in recorded history
or weather where they have had
capitalism and largely free trade if you
want to know where the masses are worse
than worse off worst off it's exactly in
the kinds of societies that depart from
that now let's face it without a solid
grounding in real fact-based economics
and history our young people are sitting
ducks for any huckster promising
freebies free health care free college
free housing and the list goes on and on
free scooters here's an indisputable
historical fact that alludes most
college professors these days there has
never been a successful socialist
government not ever a hundred million
people were killed in socialist regimes
than 20th century the USSR China Cuba
Vietnam North Korea Nicaragua ISM Bob
ley etc etc but we don't have to reach
into the annals of history to tell us
this just look at Venezuela today a
country rich in oil where the middle
class once prospered no more since Hugo
Chavez imposed socialism on the country
it is spiral to ever downward
and of course some major Hollywood
figures who were once Chavez's big
boosters the Bush administration does
not like this guy because he represents
an anti corporate interest he's taken
over the oil and he's distributed it to
the poor he certainly shove as when he
started was on the right path because he
wanted to return his country to his
people bowling for relevance more and
company is of course now devoted to
taking down Trump where they're
irrational fury as a badge of honor mr.
president Chavez employed government
controls commandeered a once free media
and presided over the collapse of his
country in a swirl of corruption unseen
even in Latin America men his successor
Nicolas Maduro took the reins the
Washington Post reporting now that
Venezuela x' crisis has steadily
intensified as a result of lower oil
prices corruption in a socialist system
played with mismanagement but as Maduro
has sought to further consolidate power
in the past twelve months the economy
public services security and health care
have all but collapsed now wonder
Venezuelans are climbing out of the
Andes to get out of there more than 10%
of the population four million people
have already departed the situation on
the ground is dire parents starved for
food are abandoning children at
orphanages power water and sanitation
services are all breaking down
government backed militias are abusing
citizens members of the military are
going AWOL due to scant rations civil
society is broken in Venezuela and crime
is on the rise oh and the people are
choking the halls of hospitals since
basic medicines are unavailable
while HIV related deaths have surged so
much for that free health care here are
the people living through the socialist
hell of present-day Venezuela listen I
live in the streets we want to solve all
these problems we don't want free
handouts we want to work
Suda there are people close to me who
picked through the garbage she says
people dressed like you and me it
affects us all Venezuela is starving we
are dying of hunger all of Venezuela
Venezuela has practically already
collapsed everyone who is out here is
hurting she says we are afraid that
either the government will kill us or
that we will die of some disease in a
hospital because there is no medicine
that is a government on socialism
despite all that though Democrats think
they can win back power touting the
Utopia of that they truly believe that
socialism is the pathway to economic
security here in America is that what
the Venezuelans are experiencing I must
be really out of it then how about the
people of Cuba who are still subjected
to rationing booklets that can script
how much food each of them can buy every
month listen to Peter loo Maj a man who
fled communist Albania on this rebranded
type of socialism is that you cannot
have a democratic socialism socialism is
is coercion socialism is forced you
cannot establish a system that people
don't want without using power what
happened 1944 is when communists came to
Albania the first thing that they did
they disarmed the population and anyone
who disagreed with them was subjected to
arrest to tortures to internment camps
my entire family was taken to a
concentration camp where my father was
tortured to death those who suffer the
most under socialism have the most to
teach us one hopes that young people are
listening closely but conservatives also
have a lot of work to do they have to do
more to outreach and and talk to the
young via education and the culture it's
our responsibility to alert those who
are not there or are too fixated on
snapchat or how much they hate Trump to
understand the dangers and horrors of
socialism but if you don't believe me
don't want to believe me that's fine I
have another idea I just booked a
one-way ticket to Venezuela stay there
for a few weeks and then get back to me
let us know how it feels to have all
that economic freedom you were looking
for
and that's the angle